I'll look at the storylines for the 20
19th season continues with a closer
consideration of the Baltimore Ravens t
more specifically the offense because
last year we saw with the Flip from Joe
Flacco to Lamar Jackson a run centric
back to the future type of an attack
where the quarterback ran the ball a lot
the team ran the ball a lot there wasn't
much passing that was done by Lamar
Jackson this year there's a presumption
that they're gonna continue to pound the
ball the way they did but I think at a
deeper level the Ravens realize they
can't win on a sustained basis because
the second time through as they learned
when they faced the Chargers in the
postseason after beating LA in late
December that it's harder to pull that
off when a team knows what that offense
is all about when they're ready to
converge on the ball and disrupt those
running plays they need to diversify the
offense and I think the Ravens have done
a nice job of keeping everyone guessing
as to what the offense is really going
to look like they weren't able to sign
many quality free agent receivers
because the perception is they're not
gonna throw the ball very much but they
drafted a couple of guys and led by
Marquis Brown they they could have that
deep threat they need to stretch the
field will they be throwing the ball or
will he be just simply running routes
without having to worry about actually
trying to catch the football when it
comes his way I think they could be
throwing the ball more than we think
Robert Griffin the third recently said
that he thinks the Ravens offense will
shock a lot of people they've got tres
McSorely the former Penn State
quarterback that they plan to develop
into a jack-of-all-trades kind of like a
Taysom Hill Saints have and it could be
a very creative attack remember Marty
mourning Wegg is out and now we have to
see how this offense moves forward with
more creativity with more imagination
with more passing than what we saw last
year and I think Greg Roman getting
together with another Harbaugh brother
remember Roman did such a great job in
San Francisco with Jim now Roman in
charge with John there's a chance that
we will see less running than we expect
more passing than we realized and for
now the reality
is no one seems to know exactly what the
Ravens are going to do and that plays
into their hands because from week one
moving forward you have defenses on
their heels
maybe they assume it's gonna be a run
based approach until they find out it
isn't the bottom line is this Lamar
Jackson showed some great passing
ability at Louisville
he was arguably better the year after he
won the Heisman in the year that he
pulled off that top individual honor and
college football this guy's got the
skills
he's got the abilities we've seen it as
a runner if we see it this year as a
passer and it translates to the NFL game
the Ravens could be a team that maybe we
should be taking a lot more seriously in
2019
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports